[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we have a new
addition
h varicose security specialized in cash
trucks across la
do you have any idea how dangerous this
job can be
yeah we ain't the predators we're the
prey
you ready ready
this is your temporary sidearm why
aren't you fully putting pistols in a
machine gun fine do you have a problem
i don't know do i it's a 10 grand drop
you should have been back five minutes
ago
they're serious leave this to me
in the truck next time sorry pal
it doesn't feel right
[Music]
it's like he wants trucks to get hit
he's not a cop but if he's not a cop
what is he
[Music]
a while back we lost two cars civilian
too
there was an investigation they still
haven't found a scum who did it
you're in an accident you're not my son
he didn't make it i need to not kill my
son
tree has been shot and it's been shook
hard
we've scorched earth always be a good
boy
you started by certainly do anything
what i'm hearing is
you think you've done everything
[Music]
i can see it's gonna be a long night
it's gotta be an inside job i can do it
in two weeks
anyone i wish you could do in 20 years
when i do bury grudge
[Music]
you